you know when we look back at history
there are periods where people fled
their country because of the turmoil at
what point do you guys think
we could we could reach is it are we
already at the point where a sane and
some person says it is not safe to be in
this country or are we still a few years
away from potentially reaching that
point like Crystal knocked or something
a lot of wealthy people have already
started to split if I understand correct
from big cities yeah well and the U.S no
I was going to say and and the
billionaire so so it's the upper class
are leaving places like New York the
billionaires are building bunkers but
I'm thinking about uh you know
kristallnacht right world World War II
era Germany
right they they went around smash up all
these Jewish businesses and everyone's
on the left you know Godwin's law
everyone's always trying to compare
everything to Nazi Germany but you can
look at a bunch of other historical
examples of mass unrest pre-breakout of
Revolution or Civil War in the instance
of Weimar Germany uh into Nazi Germany
it wasn't necessarily a civil war it was
just this cultural revolution that took
place over the over the period of
several years and without with other
countries it was over at Revolution
so when it comes to Nazi Germany you had
people fleeing well before the Nazis
Rose to power because these people like
we could see it happening in other
countries you had outright Civil War
Revolution breakout with extreme
violence in the streets and people were
fleeing now I understand if Weimar
Germany there was violence in the
streets there were Street battles but
I'm wondering what you think about the
United States will there is it possible
that ever comes a time where people say
it's not safe to be here anymore I think
it depends on whether the institutions
uh it's going to be a race right the the
left is trying to destroy the
institutions of our Republic right and
uh either take them over completely and
and and change them at their their basic
character to make them
anti-constitutional or
post-constitutional and the question is
will the American voter beat them to it
and get them out of power
uh so that same people come back in and
restore and reform those institutions
and is that possible and and um you know
what I think it's possible you know my
view is I mean imagine if just there was
a different house speaker
in the beginning of the Trump
Administration other than uh Ryan all
right someone who was you know Morehouse
Freedom caucusy right or or or or
someone uh you know you know a different
president or a different Republican
leader to me what's frustrating and both
hopeful at the same time is it doesn't
take a lot to get this reform through uh
but um it's so frustrating because it's
still not getting done even though it
doesn't take a lot to get this reform
through well let me say definitively yes
there is a point at which that could be
the case for me the two uh demarcation
points would be either uh abolition of
the Second Amendment broadly that would
be like gotta go you gotta where would
you go
somewhere where I could do it not have
to deal with the federal government but
I mean they are the Empire so it's kind
of hard to go anywhere and be any better
off ultimately but I would still
probably leave and then the second one
would be uh packing the Supreme Court if
they if they opt for that that's really
like the last line of defense thank God
that's the best thing about Trump's
presidency I've said it a thousand times
the Supreme Court Justices he put up
there like if it weren't for them I
don't think that the the vaccine mandate
from Biden gets overturned like there's
a bunch of things that don't get
overturned if it's late for Trump but
let's let's dig into that you're saying
that not even a direct threat to you if
the institution is attacked and gun
rights are gone and the Supreme Court is
packed that's enough for you to be like
we got to get out of here I think so
what do you guys think
I don't think there's anywhere to go I
think Salvador uh I I don't think left
is running things down down south I
think that I think it if the U.S were to
be in a situation where like the U.S
Falls or whatever like in a Woods is
where you're going like it's it's head
out to the Rockies get into the
mountains and live like the Wolverines I
know a lot of Bitcoin people my buddy
Jethro just moved to uh El Salvador
though I like I know it's there's a very
big tendency to just to believe that
America is the freest place on Earth and
I think historically that's true I'm not
so sure it is right now I'm not so sure
they've really fumbled this technocratic
Evolution thing yeah like it's gone too
far and but we got to remember the
concept of uniting states is where it's
at it doesn't have to be here on this
continent it's just a concept it's an
idea of delocalized authority that can
remain even if some states want to bail
or or fail
um but I think that the the states
uniting is the way of the future we'll
have probably a Earth of States United
at some point and then March that sounds
like a One World Government
even the satellite station where people
sorry Elon well it's it's just an
extrapolation of liberal democracy or
Democratic Republic but it'll be a
global tyranny instead of a local
tyranny no thank you
we're trying to avoid well they want
top-down Authority they want a centrally
controlled Globe I want decentralized
controlled Club I mean about the AI
That's What nations provide Nations that
have Sovereign power over themselves
provide
decentralized Authority you can work
together as Nations but you're not under
one globally the nation is a step of the
of the delocalization so you have you
have cities then you have States then
you have let's just go provinces
Nations then you have Globes planets and
then you have solar systems and then
you'll have galaxies oh okay and but we
gotta we've got to rule ourselves from
the local level yeah yeah right and I
and I think you know I appreciate your
point earlier Tim about you know people
want to be able to eat but Public Safety
is a pretty big deal security is a
factor and I think at the local level
these Public Safety issues eventually
um I mean even the mayor of DC is
becoming a Law and Order mayor yeah uh
you know connection Mayors in New York
and Chicago you know the problem is that
a lot of the big cities have
um you know they've they've they've put
uh their the Democrats have put their
political base they don't care they
think their votes can be taken for
granted and they don't respond to their
concerns about Public Safety but here in
DC you get Democrat politicians who are
concerned about their personal safety
things change in a minute and uh so I
think the public safety issue could be a
a significant Cutting Edge issue to get
back control of the government from the
radical extremists that are trying to
destroy definitely our institutions Sean
uh I am or Sean uh actual Justice
Warrior yeah actual Justice he has he
makes this point that that crime drives
poverty but poverty doesn't drive crime
which I think is is pretty astute like
if you have a an area that has a lot of
crime then you're not going to have
investment you don't have anybody that
wants to go in and and as much as people
on the left hate gentrification
gentrification does help the economies
of of of you know areas and stuff so if
you've got like the first thing you have
to do is stop the crime you have to get
people to stop breaking the law and as
long as you've got people as long as
your your DA's aren't putting people in
jail for looting then you're not going
to have any kind of investment and
you're going to have companies fleeing
like what's going on in multiple major
cities it's even worse than that Phil
it's not just but not putting uh you
know violent criminals away it's putting
away Good Samaritans yes yes it's like
yes it's awful it's the exact inverse of
what you should be doing absolutely so
we're all supposed to forget about the
poor guy up in New York who yeah you
know rescued all those folks on the rest
of that Homeless
you've got the guys in California who
are the 7-Eleven workers before the guy
threatens to kill them so they they beat
him up they beat him up now they're now
they're being investigated for assault
oh my God some kind of weapon but they
they beat on him for a while and he had
a weapon on it did he yeah he pulled out
some kind of weapon and threatened them
he banished a weapon that's not assault
You Gotta Eat him in a submission at
that point and then we stopped all they
had was a stick if they stopped does
he'd get up and just start stabbing him
or shooting him who knows apparently he
threatened to shoot these guys so what
can they do other than try to
incapacitate him otherwise they'll get
shot yeah and if they had a gun shooting
them would have been probably been
legally easier not in California yeah
well I mean the president already
for the record actual Justice Warriors
Sean Fitzgerald Fitzgerald that's it
yeah he's great yeah he's really really
smart
uh I'm I'm trying to answer your
question Tim if there's a point I mean
obviously if the Bill of Rights starts
to become overturned I I think this idea
of like institutional limits
I'm I'm not as concerned I mean
obviously the Second Amendment goes away
it's very very bad but that that it that
precipitates the point of no that that
is that is before I guess what I mean to
say is
when we're we're looking at them right
now arresting their political opponents
yeah that's the test I mean I I think
the Trump thing is that big tests if
they go after really disturbing so so
Trump is the point where it's like okay
it's getting dark this is their
political rival now now if they do
indict Giuliani I gotta say I think
that's the point where historically many
people said they fled the country
because going after an attorney who is
advising someone shows that you have a
regime you no longer have a government
and that they will come for anyone who
expresses discontent I already feel that
way and you have the state these points
I'm talking about speech like right
right Giuliani talking to Trump if they
do indict him then You're Next Media
personalities commentators people on
Twitter they'll come after they already
had you Tom in front of a grand jury
you're looking at my door at my home
they sent the FBI to the home to the
home of the head of the country's
largest government Watchdog organization
I gotta be honest this is that's
interesting
where you already have families being
like well actually I heard something
interesting people leaving people who
migrated here saying they're going back
to their home countries and things like
that I met a guy from El Salvador and he
said he was returning back home because
it's safer there than here now I don't
know if I really think what you're
describing is already going on it's just
that the United States being the org
being organized the way that it is with
multiple States in one Federal
jurisdiction that's why you see people
leaving California and and people that
are you know leaving there are people
I'm sure leaving red States although I'm
sure there's far fewer stupid people but
there are people that are you know we're
organizing and segregating ourselves by
our political opinions more you know
ever as every day goes on there are more
and more people that do that that's why
they want to ban cars well you know and
have us all live in 15 minutes city
slash gulags you ain't lying when when
we look back at history we ask ourselves
like how could it get so bad how did it
get so bad in Germany how did it go from
one point to the other and the issue is
that these things happen slowly one step
at a time over long periods of time the
American Revolution was a 20-year period
it's not like the crowns had a bunch of
nasty things and then we were like you
know what we're going to declare
independence and a lot of people we we
talked about this when did we actually
gain our Independence was until years
after 1776 what was it like a 1781 or
something like that or
83.89 is when the is when the
Constitution was ready 83 I think was
the Treaty of Paris okay so there's a
there's a reason that the republics
haven't been around for a long time yeah
and we're running into it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time